ce week-end on est à grenoble pour folk
pourquoi pardon pour faire la plus
grande de leurs modèles de france et
comme c'est pas connu en dehors de la
france finalement la plus grande de leur
modèle du monde ça avec amg la ville de
grenoble vraiment merci à eux
on a vécu un truc de dingue qu'on
attendait maximum 1000 personnes pour
danser avec nous la danse évidemment de
bas de la grande danseuse et 8 a été
grand danseur
eh bien regardez merci à graignes à
plein de choses qui se sont passées
vraiment ou a été comme des dingues déjà
l arrivée regardez ça le monde qui a
pour sept de leurs modèles 6
sauf
les amis ne sauraient toujours gardé une
âme ans et j'ai pu me rendre compte que
c'est des vrais fans de l'émission ils
suivent vraiment tous les jours les
grenoblois ces raisons monsieur alors
que les gens étaient comme des d'heure
on n'a qu'à m'appeler cyril on dirait
qu'ils poulet qui pouvaient pas venir
est en repos musculaires liées au
secteur est très important pour lui je
vous jure le samedi que les attentions
avec ça on a un pc reid en direct
regarder
alors
et la mongolie
et
tout ça pour la dollar monnaie alors est
ce qu'on l'a celle de l'or ouhlala de
leur modeste bien sûr 5000 grenoblois
condensé la de leur mode est vraiment
vous êtes des anges merci mille fois les
ami es fou on a quelques images ça a
duré pendant quatre cinq minutes on a
fait un petit pas regardez-la de leur
mode s c'est parti c'est maintenant
direct de grenoble c'est fou ce de leurs
modems ce qu'on fasse un jour tu vois je
vois pas non plus les écouteurs les
toits il faut qu'une horde tout là bas
vous devez l'avis officiel
je
seuls leurs modèles
tous
de leurs modèles